Add a pop of culture to every room in your house with SiriusXM. Stream over 425 channels of ad-free music, plus exclusive talk, world-class news, live play-by-play sports, comedy, and popular podcasts with the SXM app. Subscribe to the streaming platinum plan and get your first three months for free. Visit SiriusXM.ca for details. SiriusXM, everything you want to hear, lives here. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre.
使用 SiriusXM，为您家中的每个房间增添一抹文化气息。通过 SXM 应用程序，您可以畅享 425 多个无广告音乐频道，以及独家谈话节目、世界级新闻、现场体育赛事直播、喜剧和热门播客。订阅流媒体白金套餐，前三个月免费。详情请访问 SiriusXM.ca。SiriusXM，您想听的一切，尽在于此。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。
For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. Four-year-old Kevin Yolmeson loved his bicycle more than anything. The little boy was a familiar face around Dottavik, the small Swedish suburb he lived in with his mother Therese and half-sister Isabella. He was often seen riding happily around the neighbourhood, waving to those he knew as he cycled by.
如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本集的节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，可能并不适合所有听众。四岁的凯文·约尔梅森（Kevin Yolmeson）最爱他的自行车。这个小男孩在多塔维克（Dottavik）是个熟面孔，这是他与母亲特蕾丝（Therese）和同母异父的妹妹伊莎贝拉（Isabella）居住的瑞典小郊区。人们经常看到他骑着车在社区里快乐地穿梭，骑车经过时还会向认识的人挥手致意。
The residential area was located on the shores of the Sjirkeviken Bay, just three kilometres outside Central Arvika. It was a close-knit community and residents mostly trusted one another. Therefore, it was common practice for the local children to play around town without supervision, provided they steer clear of the main roads and lake. They never veered too far and a familiar adult was never too far away. Sunday, August 16, 1998 was the last day of holidays before school returned for the year and the sun made a much welcome appearance.
该住宅区位于希尔克维肯湾（Sjirkeviken Bay）岸边，距离阿尔维卡（Arvika）市中心仅三公里。这是一个关系紧密的社区，居民们大多互相信任。因此，当地儿童在无人看管的情况下在镇上玩耍是惯例，只要他们远离主干道和湖泊即可。他们从不走得太远，熟悉的成年人也总是在附近。1998 年 8 月 16 日星期日是学校开学前假期的最后一天，阳光明媚，令人倍感欣慰。
It was the perfect opportunity for Kevin Yolmeson to play outside on his bike. After breakfast, he rode over to meet his friend Robin and the two played all morning before Kevin went to his grandparents' house for lunch. Afterwards, he ducked home where his mother Therese was busy preparing for Isabella's return to school the following day. She agreed to let Kevin go out again as long as he didn't stay out too late. By 6.30pm, Kevin hadn't returned home and Therese was starting to worry. Hoping he'd just lost track of time and was busy playing somewhere, she enlisted Kevin's
这对凯文·约尔梅森来说是骑车在户外玩耍的绝佳机会。早餐后，他骑车去见了他的朋友罗宾（Robin），两人玩了一整个上午，然后凯文去了祖父母家吃午饭。之后，他跑回家，母亲特蕾丝正忙着为伊莎贝拉第二天返校做准备。她同意让凯文再出去玩，只要他不玩得太晚。到了下午 6 点 30 分，凯文还没有回家，特蕾丝开始担心起来。她希望他只是玩得忘了时间，于是请凯文的
grandparents to help her look around town. They searched Kevin's usual haunts, including the playgrounds, local school and football field, but there was no sign of him anywhere. The football field backed on to Sheikveek and Bay, a large lake dotted with trees and walking paths. They followed the path towards the lake where his grandmother noticed something propped up against a grassy mound behind a small wooden shed. It was Kevin's bicycle, his prized possession which he took with him everywhere.
祖父母帮她在镇上四处寻找。他们搜寻了凯文常去的地方，包括游乐场、当地学校和足球场，但到处都没有他的踪影。足球场背靠希尔克维肯湾，这是一个点缀着树木和步行道的大湖。他们沿着小路走向湖边，祖母注意到一个小木棚后的草堆旁立着什么东西。那是凯文的自行车，他最珍贵的宝贝，去哪儿都带着它。
Dred washed over Kevin's family. They called Kevin's name, but there was no response. Something must be horribly wrong. There was no way Kevin would stray too far from his beloved bike. Like the other children in the neighborhood, Kevin was strictly forbidden from playing near the lake, a rule he happily obeyed as he couldn't swim and was afraid of the water. However, a sailboat was bobbing in the water and his family wondered if Kevin might have been interested enough to get a closer look.
恐惧笼罩了凯文的家人。他们呼喊着凯文的名字，但没有任何回应。一定出了什么可怕的事情。凯文绝不可能离他心爱的自行车太远。像社区里的其他孩子一样，凯文被严禁在湖边玩耍，他很乐意遵守这条规则，因为他不会游泳，而且怕水。然而，水面上漂浮着一艘帆船，他的家人想知道凯文是否因为好奇而想凑近看看。
They trepidatiously headed towards the lake, calling Kevin's name repeatedly as they walked. At the shore, Kevin's grandfather glanced over towards an area of reeds and slumped over in shock. There, lying face down on a wooden pallet amongst the reeds, was Kevin. Kevin's grandfather carried Kevin's lifeless body to shore and his grandmother administered mouth-to-mouth resuscitation while waiting for the paramedics. Kevin was rushed to hospital, but all attempts to revive him were fruitless. At 11pm, he was officially pronounced deceased with the cause of death determined to be drowning.
他们战战兢兢地走向湖边，一边走一边反复呼喊凯文的名字。在岸边，凯文的祖父看向一片芦苇丛，震惊得瘫倒在地。凯文正脸朝下躺在芦苇丛中的木托盘上。凯文的祖父将凯文毫无生气的身体抱上岸，祖母在等待医护人员时进行了口对口人工呼吸。凯文被紧急送往医院，但所有的抢救尝试都徒劳无功。晚上 11 点，他被正式宣告死亡，死因确定为溺水。
It was standard protocol for local law enforcement to look into drowning incidents and as soon as investigators saw Kevin's body, they knew this wasn't a typical drowning case. For starters, Kevin's shoes and one of his socks were missing. There were also visible injuries to the front of his neck and abdomen. While it was possible that these injuries were caused by his body rubbing against the wooden pallet as it moved in the water, this was unlikely. The pallet Kevin had been found lying on was in water approximately 20cm deep. When his grandparents found him, only his left hand had been trailing in the water while
当地执法部门调查溺水事件是标准程序，调查人员一看到凯文的尸体，就知道这不是典型的溺水案件。首先，凯文的鞋子和一只袜子不见了。他的脖子前部和腹部也有明显的伤痕。虽然这些伤可能是他的身体在水中移动时与木托盘摩擦造成的，但这不太可能。凯文被发现时躺着的托盘在约 20 厘米深的水中。当他的祖父母发现他时，只有他的左手拖在水里，而
the rest of his body was afloat on the pallet. Even though Kevin couldn't swim, it didn't make sense that he could have drowned in such shallow water. An official autopsy confirmed investigators' suspicions. The whites of Kevin's eyes showed clear signs of bleeding which is a telltale indication of strangulation. There were also bruises to his genitals and signs of sexual assault as well as sand in his underwear.
他身体的其他部分漂浮在托盘上。尽管凯文不会游泳，但在这么浅的水里溺水是不合理的。官方尸检证实了调查人员的怀疑。凯文眼白处有明显的出血迹象，这是勒死的典型征兆。他的生殖器也有瘀伤，并有性侵犯的迹象，内裤里还有沙子。
This wasn't a tragic drowning accident at all, but a cold blooded murder. The area where Kevin's body was found was cordoned off, although authorities kept it under wraps that they were investigating the boy's death as anything other than an accident. The local school was right next door, so parents and children arrived to a dramatic scene when they returned for the school year on Monday morning. As officers assessed the area, two students approached and handed over a pair of black of velcro strapped sandals and a single purple sock. They belonged to Kevin, and the children had found them behind the small shed where his
这根本不是一场悲惨的溺水事故，而是一起冷血谋杀。发现凯文尸体的区域被封锁了，尽管当局对外保密，称他们正在调查这名男孩的死因，而非仅仅是事故。当地学校就在隔壁，所以周一早上学生们返校时，家长和孩子们目睹了这一戏剧性的场景。当警察评估该区域时，两名学生走过来，交出了一双黑色魔术贴凉鞋和一只紫色袜子。它们属于凯文，孩子们是在他自行车被遗弃的小棚子后面发现的。
bike had been abandoned. The shed was approximately 30 metres from where Kevin's body was found, and the path leading up to it contained similar sand to that which was found in Kevin's underwear. This led investigators to theorise that he could have been killed near the shed before being moved to the pallet. Fluorescent clothing fibres were found on the path, although none were detected on the pallet or on Kevin's body. A seven-centimetre-long bruise on Kevin's neck indicated that he'd been killed by someone
棚子距离发现凯文尸体的地方约 30 米，通往棚子的小路上有与凯文内裤里发现的沙子相似的沙子。这导致调查人员推测他可能是在棚子附近被杀，然后才被移到托盘上的。小路上发现了荧光衣物纤维，但在托盘或凯文的尸体上没有检测到。凯文脖子上 7 厘米长的瘀伤表明他是被某人
pressing a hard, sharp object against his throat. Investigators were particularly interested in a stick that was found near the shed. It was around one-centimetre thick and broken in the middle. Testing revealed a child-sized handprint in the bark, as well as several hairs attached, leading to the conclusion that this was the murder weapon. Given the proximity of the crime scene to the school, the rumour mill soon went into overdrive. Police had been canvassing the neighbourhood to question people about what they'd seen
用坚硬、锋利的物体抵住喉咙而死的。调查人员对在棚子附近发现的一根棍子特别感兴趣。它大约一厘米厚，中间断了。检测显示树皮上有儿童大小的手印，还附着几根头发，这得出了它是凶器的结论。鉴于犯罪现场靠近学校，谣言工厂很快就超负荷运转了。警察一直在社区进行走访，询问人们关于周日下午所见的情况，
on Sunday afternoon, making it obvious that this was no open-and-shut accidental drowning. On Thursday, August 20, local suspicions that something more sinister was at play were confirmed when a press conference was held to announce that the police were now treating Kevin's death as a sexual assault and murder. Kevin's parents were grief-stricken. They had separated before he was born, but his father, Portric, had recently moved closer to Dr Vic to focus on his relationship with his son. The two had been growing closer, and to have Kevin suddenly snatched away left Portric
这显然不是一起简单的意外溺水案。8 月 20 日星期四，当新闻发布会宣布警方现在将凯文的死视为性侵犯和谋杀案时，当地关于有更险恶事件发生的猜测得到了证实。凯文的父母悲痛欲绝。他们在凯文出生前就分开了，但他的父亲波特里克（Portric）最近搬到了离多塔维克更近的地方，以便专注于与儿子的关系。两人的关系正变得越来越亲密，凯文突然被夺走，让波特里克
so overcome with sorrow that he was unable to leave the house. Kevin's mother, Therese, shied away from the media to focus on her grief and take care of her daughter, while also trying to process unfounded accusations of neglect. Though much of the community were supportive, some parents were openly questioning how Therese could have left Kevin unsupervised. She was accused of partying instead of taking care of her children. Others cruelly labelled Kevin's grandparents as drunks, and some went as far as to comment. It was no wonder that he died.
悲痛欲绝，以至于无法离开家门。凯文的母亲特蕾丝避开媒体，专注于自己的悲伤并照顾女儿，同时还要努力应对毫无根据的疏忽指控。尽管社区里很多人表示支持，但一些家长公开质疑特蕾丝怎么能让凯文处于无人看管的状态。她被指责只顾聚会而不照顾孩子。其他人残忍地称凯文的祖父母为酒鬼，甚至有人评论说，他死了也不足为奇。
This cruel gossip exacerbated Therese's already overwhelming grief. As most child murders are committed by someone known to the victim, protocol dictated that Kevin's family were looked into. Not only did they all have verified alibis, but police found nothing to suggest that they were anything other than loving and supportive, and they were quickly ruled out of the investigation. Police had been trying to piece together Kevin's last known movements, but this was no easy task. Drvik was a relatively lower socioeconomic area, and many residents didn't trust the
这些残酷的流言加剧了特蕾丝本已难以承受的悲伤。由于大多数儿童谋杀案都是受害者认识的人所为，协议规定必须调查凯文的家人。他们不仅都有经过核实的不在场证明，而且警方没有发现任何迹象表明他们不是充满爱心和支持的家人，因此他们很快被排除在调查之外。警方一直在试图拼凑凯文最后已知的行踪，但这并非易事。多塔维克是一个相对社会经济地位较低的地区，许多居民不信任
police as they felt they'd been overlooked when making reports in the past. Eventually, investigators found some who were willing to talk, and a timeline was established. After Kevin left his mother's house on Sunday afternoon, he met up with a friend named Robert. Just before 4pm, the pair rode their bikes to the home of Kevin's best friend, Robin, and asked if he wanted to come out and play. Robin wasn't allowed to, so Kevin told Robin he'd come by the next day instead. He and Robert then ran into a 13-year-old they knew named Felix, not his real name. The boys looked up to Felix because he owned an impressive BMX bike with Spider-Man handlebars.
警察，因为他们觉得过去在报案时被忽视了。最终，调查人员找到了一些愿意交谈的人，并确定了时间表。凯文周日下午离开母亲家后，遇到了一个叫罗伯特（Robert）的朋友。下午 4 点前，两人骑自行车去了凯文最好的朋友罗宾（Robin）家，问他是否想出来玩。罗宾不被允许，所以凯文告诉罗宾他第二天再来。随后，他和罗伯特遇到了一个他们认识的 13 岁男孩菲利克斯（Felix，化名）。男孩们很崇拜菲利克斯，因为他有一辆带有蜘蛛侠车把的炫酷小轮车（BMX）。
When Robert left to go home, Kevin was still with Felix. He then played in the school yard with a group of other local teens and children, none of whom recalled seeing any strangers or anything suspicious in the area. Several local residents had heard screaming at around 6pm, but hadn't been able to figure out where the noise was coming from. One person had gotten into their car and driven around trying to locate the source, to no avail. The injuries to Kevin's genital area indicated the crime may have been sexually motivated. There were three known pedophiles who resided around Dr Vic, one of whom lived just 100
当罗伯特回家时，凯文还和菲利克斯在一起。之后，他在学校操场和一群当地青少年及儿童玩耍，他们中没有人记得在附近看到过任何陌生人或可疑情况。一些当地居民在下午 6 点左右听到了尖叫声，但无法确定声音来自哪里。有人甚至开车四处寻找声源，但一无所获。凯文生殖器部位的伤势表明犯罪可能具有性动机。在多塔维克附近居住着三名已知的恋童癖者，其中一人就住在离凯文家仅 100
metres from Kevin's home. According to witnesses, this individual was seen at around midday on Sunday, holding Kevin's hand and helping him cross the street. However, he had a verified alibi for that evening, as did the other two known child sex offenders. Plus, there was no evidence linking any of them to the murder weapon. Daily press conferences were held to keep the public and media up to date with the latest developments in what came to be known as the Kevin case, but the details of how Kevin
米的地方。据目击者称，此人在周日中午左右被看到牵着凯文的手，帮他过马路。然而，他有当晚的核实不在场证明，另外两名已知的儿童性犯罪者也是如此。此外，没有证据将他们中的任何一人与凶器联系起来。警方每天举行新闻发布会，向公众和媒体通报被称为“凯文案”的最新进展，但凯文的死因细节
died were withheld. Given the sensitive nature of the crime, lead investigator Rolf Sundberry decided that a restrained approach was best, to prevent hysteria and keep speculation to a minimum. Police appealed for anyone with information to come forward, but all they got was a series of false leads. One woman implicated her partner in the crime, while another claimed a hitman had been hired to kill Kevin. There was no evidence to support either of these claims.
被隐瞒了。鉴于犯罪的敏感性，首席调查员罗尔夫·桑德伯里（Rolf Sundberry）决定采取克制的方法，以防止歇斯底里并将猜测降至最低。警方呼吁任何有信息的人挺身而出，但他们得到的只是一系列虚假线索。一名女子指控她的伴侣犯下了罪行，而另一名女子则声称有人雇佣了杀手来杀害凯文。没有证据支持这些说法。
Questions were soon raised as to whether Kevin had been sexually assaulted at all. The pathologist who'd initially examined Kevin's body had detected white liquid around the four-year-old's rectum, and had partly based the sexual assault diagnosis on this evidence. Upon closer inspection, he realized the liquid was actually from the thermometer that had been used to determine Kevin's approximate time of death. Police were under immense pressure to make an arrest. Not only was Kevin's death starting to make national headlines, the community had become cloaked in fear.
人们很快提出了疑问，凯文是否真的受到了性侵犯。最初检查凯文尸体的病理学家在四岁男孩的直肠周围发现了白色液体，并部分基于此证据做出了性侵犯的诊断。经过仔细检查，他意识到液体实际上来自用于确定凯文大致死亡时间的温度计。警方承受着巨大的破案压力。凯文的死不仅开始登上全国头条，整个社区也笼罩在恐惧之中。
Children were no longer allowed to play or walk to school unsupervised, with their parents on edge that a child killer was on the loose. Adding fuel to the fire were rumors and tip-offs that immigrants were responsible. Several of the children last seen playing with Kevin were refugees, including 13-year-old Felix. Theories arose that one of the foreign children had murdered Kevin, but were refusing to admit to it because their parents had threatened to kill them if they owned up. These children had fled from war-torn countries where they'd witnessed all kinds of atrocities,
孩子们不再被允许在无人看管的情况下玩耍或步行上学，家长们担心有杀童犯在逃。火上浇油的是关于移民是罪魁祸首的谣言和举报。最后几个和凯文一起玩的孩子中，有几名是难民，包括 13 岁的菲利克斯。有理论认为其中一名外国孩子谋杀了凯文，但因为父母威胁说如果承认就杀了他们，所以拒绝承认。这些孩子从饱受战争蹂躏的国家逃出来，目睹了各种暴行，
and some believed this could have influenced their behavior. Although police were eager to dispel these rumors to quell any growing xenophobia, interviewing these children proved difficult. Not only were there cultural differences, but given the children's experiences with war, some of them had learned not to trust authorities. It was clear to police that some of them weren't telling the truth. They just couldn't tell if this was because they genuinely had something to hide, or because they simply didn't want to get into trouble.
有些人认为这可能影响了他们的行为。尽管警方急于消除这些谣言以平息日益增长的仇外心理，但采访这些孩子证明很困难。不仅存在文化差异，而且鉴于孩子们在战争中的经历，他们中的一些人已经学会了不信任当局。警方很清楚，他们中的一些人没有说实话。他们只是无法判断这是因为他们真的有什么隐瞒，还是因为他们只是不想惹麻烦。
It soon came to light that the children who'd handed in Kevin's shoes to police only knew they were behind the shed because Felix had told them so. His knowledge about the shoes, along with the fact that he was one of the last people seen with Kevin, led to rumors that Felix had something to do with Kevin's death. However, Felix told police he didn't hang out with Kevin at all. If witnesses claimed they saw the two of them together, they were mistaken. He had indeed been riding his BMX bike around town, but he had gone to the library at around 6pm before heading home.
很快人们发现，那些把凯文的鞋子交给警察的孩子之所以知道鞋子在棚子后面，是因为菲利克斯告诉他们的。他对鞋子的了解，加上他是最后见到凯文的人之一，导致了关于菲利克斯与凯文之死有关的谣言。然而，菲利克斯告诉警察他根本没有和凯文在一起。如果目击者声称看到他们两个在一起，那他们看错了。他确实骑着小轮车在镇上转悠，但在下午 6 点左右去了图书馆，然后才回家。
Having successfully eliminated Kevin's family and known sex offenders from the investigation, police focused on the children who had been seen playing with or near Kevin on the night of his death. However, questioning young children regarding criminal matters is challenging at the best of times. Not only did the children's limited vocabulary make it difficult to have straightforward conversations, but police also had to avoid asking any leading questions. Complicating matters further was the fact that many of the children weren't allowed to play
在成功将凯文的家人和已知的性犯罪者排除在调查之外后，警方将重点放在了案发当晚被看到与凯文一起玩耍或在附近玩耍的孩子身上。然而，在最好的情况下，就刑事问题询问年幼的孩子也是具有挑战性的。不仅孩子们有限的词汇量使得进行直接对话变得困难，而且警察还必须避免提出任何诱导性问题。更复杂的是，许多孩子不被允许在
near the lake, so they lied and told police they weren't in the area. They changed their stories constantly, sometimes implicating other children, then later taking it back. With some parents flatly refusing to let their children speak to the police, they were urged to speak with their children themselves and report anything that could be of interest to the investigation. The police weren't used to questioning children regarding such serious matters, and they didn't know how to interpret their constantly changing answers.
湖边玩耍，所以他们撒谎告诉警察他们不在那个区域。他们不断改变说法，有时牵连其他孩子，后来又收回。由于一些家长断然拒绝让他们的孩子与警察交谈，他们被敦促自己与孩子交谈，并报告任何可能对调查有意义的事情。警察不习惯就如此严重的问题询问孩子，他们不知道如何解读他们不断变化的回答。
Unsure what to think or how best to proceed, they enlisted the help of professionals who were trained in dealing with children, including those with different cultural backgrounds. They brought child and family psychologists on board, as well as social workers and representatives from charity organization Save the Children. Ingrid Horeson was a child psychologist trained in dealing with victims of sexual assault, and she was tasked to assist police with the interrogations. It was important that she built rapport with the children, so they felt safe and comfortable enough to talk.
由于不确定该怎么想或如何进行，他们寻求了受过处理儿童问题（包括有不同文化背景的儿童）培训的专业人员的帮助。他们请来了儿童和家庭心理学家，以及社会工作者和慈善组织“救助儿童会”的代表。英格丽德·霍雷森（Ingrid Horeson）是一位受过处理性侵犯受害者培训的儿童心理学家，她被指派协助警方进行审讯。重要的是她要与孩子们建立融洽的关系，让他们感到足够安全和舒适，从而愿意开口。
Horeson, along with some of the others on the interrogation team, spent time playing with the children and chatting with them over barbecues, fishing excursions and soccer games. Toys, video games and sweet treats were brought into the station to help put the children at ease. Once the children felt comfortable, Horeson and another detective would interview them in a private room, while others in the team watched on via a covert TV screen. Horeson wore an earpiece so that another child psychologist named Bent Joran Jornson could guide her on how she should behave, what questions she should focus on, and how far she could
霍雷森和审讯小组的其他成员花时间与孩子们一起玩耍，在烧烤、钓鱼和足球比赛中与他们聊天。玩具、电子游戏和甜食被带到警察局，以帮助孩子们放松。一旦孩子们感到舒适，霍雷森和另一名侦探会在私人房间里采访他们，而小组中的其他人则通过隐蔽的电视屏幕观看。霍雷森戴着耳机，以便另一位名叫本特·乔兰·乔恩森（Bent Joran Jornson）的儿童心理学家可以指导她的行为、她应该关注的问题以及她可以
push the children. For many of the children, Kevin's death was difficult to comprehend, although they understood that he would no longer be around. Kevin's murder was a hot topic around the neighborhood, and Kevin's best friend, five-year-old Robin Dalyan had heard plenty of the stories that were floating around. His seven-year-old brother Christian had just started school and came home every day rehashing everything that he'd heard in the schoolyard. Police had stopped by to question Robin and Christian several times, as Kevin visited
将孩子们推到什么程度。对于许多孩子来说，凯文的死很难理解，尽管他们明白他不会再出现了。凯文的谋杀案是社区里的热门话题，凯文最好的朋友、五岁的罗宾·达利安（Robin Dalyan）听到了很多流传的故事。他七岁的哥哥克里斯蒂安（Christian）刚开始上学，每天回家都会复述他在学校操场上听到的一切。警察曾多次停下来询问罗宾和克里斯蒂安，因为凯文在被杀那天下午去过
their home on the afternoon he was killed. Robin hadn't been allowed to go out and play, as his family had guests over for dinner. Robin and Christian's father, Vyna Dalyan, told police that after dinner the boys had played outside with the children of their guests. They then all left to go on a fishing trip. While they couldn't provide any information about the night in question, Vyna agreed to make note of anything his sons might mention that could be of any interest to police. Like some of his neighbors, he trusted law enforcement and wanted to help in any way
他们家。罗宾不被允许出去玩，因为家里有客人吃晚饭。罗宾和克里斯蒂安的父亲维纳·达利安（Vyna Dalyan）告诉警察，晚饭后男孩们和客人的孩子们在外面玩。然后他们都去钓鱼了。虽然他们无法提供关于案发当晚的任何信息，但维纳同意记下儿子们可能提到的任何对警察有意义的事情。像他的一些邻居一样，他信任执法部门，并希望以任何可能的方式提供帮助。
possible. According to the book The Story of the Kevin Case by Andreas Slatt, on Saturday, August 22, six days after Kevin's death, Vyna was driving the boys to buy some sweets when he overheard Christian say, I saw Kevin standing and talking to some big guys on the day that he died. Realising this was exactly the kind of information that could be helpful to the police, Vyna immediately rerouted the car towards the police station. Just before they arrived, Robin suddenly announced,
根据安德烈亚斯·斯莱特（Andreas Slatt）所著的《凯文案的故事》一书，8 月 22 日星期六，即凯文死后六天，维纳正开车带男孩们去买糖果，无意中听到克里斯蒂安说：“我看到凯文在死的那天站着和几个大个子说话。”意识到这正是对警察有帮助的信息，维纳立即将车转向警察局。就在他们到达之前，罗宾突然宣布，
I saw the murder Kevin. Vyna was taken aback. He didn't think his sons had been playing down by the lake on the night Kevin was killed, but Robin insisted he was telling the truth. Vyna didn't want to take any chances. Perhaps the boys had ridden to the lake while they were playing in front of the house after dinner. He figured the boys could tell the police what they knew, and the police could then figure
“我看到了谋杀凯文的人。”维纳大吃一惊。他以为儿子们在凯文被杀的那晚没有在湖边玩耍，但罗宾坚持说他说的是实话。维纳不想冒险。也许男孩们在晚饭后在屋前玩耍时骑车去了湖边。他想男孩们可以告诉警察他们知道的事情，然后警察就可以弄清楚
out if any of the information was useful. At the station, Robin and Christian were taken into separate rooms to tell police what they knew. Robin was accompanied by his stepmother Eva. She and Vyna had recently married, and they had main custody of the two boys, who also split their time with their mother, Annika. The police probed Robin to tell them everything he knew about who killed Kevin, but Robin was reluctant.
是否有任何有用的信息。在警察局，罗宾和克里斯蒂安被带到不同的房间告诉警察他们知道的情况。罗宾由他的继母伊娃（Eva）陪同。她和维纳最近结婚了，他们拥有这两个男孩的主要监护权，男孩们也与他们的母亲安妮卡（Annika）分担时间。警察盘问罗宾，让他告诉他们关于谁杀了凯文的一切，但罗宾很勉强。
Eva reassured him he wouldn't get in trouble if he admitted he had rode his bike down to the lake. Robin denied doing so, but then said, They didn't listen. Who didn't listen, the officer asked. Robin responded, The one who murdered Kevin. He said there were two boys, one wore all black while the other wore grey pants and a black jumper. Robin had watched as they stabbed Kevin in the stomach.
伊娃安慰他说，如果他承认自己骑自行车去了湖边，他不会有麻烦。罗宾否认了，但随后说：“他们不听。”“谁不听？”警察问。罗宾回答说：“那个谋杀凯文的人。”他说有两个男孩，一个全身黑，另一个穿着灰色裤子和黑色套头衫。罗宾看着他们用刀刺向凯文的肚子。
Given that Kevin had died by strangulation, this was obviously incorrect, but police weren't prepared to rule Robin's account out. Due to his age, it was possible that he was simply getting the details of his story mixed up. Meanwhile, in the other room, Christian told police that on the night of Sunday, August 16, Robin had told him that he watched Kevin's murder. It became clear to police that the brothers could be the key witnesses they'd been waiting for.
鉴于凯文是死于勒死，这显然是不正确的，但警方并没有准备排除罗宾的说法。由于他的年龄，他很可能只是把故事的细节搞混了。与此同时，在另一个房间里，克里斯蒂安告诉警察，在 8 月 16 日星期日晚上，罗宾告诉他，他目睹了凯文的谋杀案。警方很清楚，这对兄弟可能是他们一直在等待的关键证人。
The news that Robin had witnessed Kevin's murder came as such a shock to his stepmother Eva that she had a panic attack and had to be administered to a psychiatric ward. She was overcome with fear that whoever had killed Kevin would target Robin next to ensure his silence. She was heavily sedated and held in the hospital for nine days. Police visited Eva in hospital and asked if she remembered the boys saying anything about seeing Kevin's murder on the night that he died. She recalled that Christian might have said something about Kevin's murder on the night
罗宾目睹了凯文谋杀案的消息让他的继母伊娃感到震惊，她惊恐发作，不得不被送往精神病院。她极度恐惧，担心杀害凯文的人会为了确保罗宾保持沉默而对他下手。她被注射了强效镇静剂，并在医院住了九天。警察去医院探望伊娃，询问她是否记得男孩们提到过在凯文死的那晚看到谋杀案。她回忆起克里斯蒂安可能在案发当晚提到过凯文的谋杀案。
it happened. When pushed, she also conceded that Christian's clothing might have been wet. For the police, this was a major breakthrough that proved the brothers really had witnessed the murder. Police took Robin to visit the scene of the crime, hoping it would jog his memory, but his story changed constantly, leaving more questions than answers. They took him to Kevin's neighborhood and asked if he could identify the killer, but Robin simply knocked on doors at random.
当被追问时，她也承认克里斯蒂安的衣服可能是湿的。对警察来说，这是一个重大突破，证明了兄弟俩确实目睹了谋杀。警察带罗宾去参观犯罪现场，希望这能唤起他的记忆，但他的故事不断变化，留下的问题多于答案。他们带他去了凯文的社区，问他是否能认出凶手，但罗宾只是随机敲门。
They showed Robin the yearbook from the local school and asked if he could identify the person who had killed Kevin. He first pointed to one boy, but then changed his mind and pointed to another. One of the perpetrators he singled out shared any physical characteristics, making it clear that Robin was just pointing to pictures at random. Robin then changed his mind completely and said the killer wasn't in the yearbook at all. With the very little physical evidence to go on, police knew their best chance of solving
他们给罗宾看了当地学校的年鉴，问他是否能认出杀害凯文的人。他先指了一个男孩，但后来改变主意指了另一个。他挑出的其中一个肇事者与任何身体特征都不符，这清楚地表明罗宾只是在随机指认照片。罗宾随后完全改变了主意，说凶手根本不在年鉴里。由于几乎没有物证，警察知道他们破案的最佳机会是找到可靠的证人。
the case was to find reliable witnesses. Robin began telling the police that his brother Christian had also seen Kevin's murder. Christian initially denied seeing anything, but finally admitted that he had been with Robin on the night Kevin died. They had seen him get into a fight with a group of other local kids. Police narrowed their focus onto eight young individuals who had been spotted playing in the area on the night of the crime. They picked the children up from school and took them to the station so they could interview
罗宾开始告诉警察，他的哥哥克里斯蒂安也看到了凯文的谋杀案。克里斯蒂安最初否认看到任何东西，但最终承认他在凯文死的那晚和罗宾在一起。他们看到他和一群其他当地孩子打架。警方将重点缩小到八名在案发当晚被发现在该地区玩耍的年轻人身上。他们从学校接走这些孩子，带到警察局，以便在没有家长影响的情况下采访他们，这一决定受到了严厉批评。
them without parental influence, a decision that was harshly criticized. The spotlight was soon placed on two 13-year-old boys named Marios and Matias, who had been seen near the lake around the time Kevin went missing. When questioned by police, they gave evasive answers and constantly changed their stories. Police became increasingly convinced that the two friends were lying to cover something up, but they had no evidence to prove it. They searched the boys' homes and confiscated several items of clothing for forensic testing. Nothing of interest was found.
聚光灯很快集中在两名 13 岁的男孩马里奥斯（Marios）和马蒂亚斯（Matias）身上，他们在凯文失踪时被看到在湖边附近。当被警察询问时，他们回答闪烁其词，并不断改变说法。警方越来越确信这两个朋友在撒谎以掩盖什么，但他们没有证据证明这一点。他们搜查了男孩们的家，没收了几件衣服进行法医鉴定。没有发现任何有价值的东西。
The handprint on the stick that was believed to be the murder weapon was compared to several of the children last seen with Kevin, but there were no matches. Instead, it was theorized that Kevin himself might have held onto the stick while trying to fight off the attack. As Kevin's prints weren't ever taken, this couldn't be determined with certainty. One month into the investigation, police remained convinced that Matias and Marios knew more than they were letting on. So they applied extra pressure during their interrogations in a bid to extract the truth.
被认为是凶器的那根棍子上的手印被拿来与最后见到凯文的几个孩子进行比对，但没有匹配。相反，有人推测凯文自己在试图抵御攻击时可能抓住了棍子。由于从未提取过凯文的指纹，这一点无法确定。调查进行了一个月，警方仍然确信马蒂亚斯和马里奥斯知道的比他们透露的要多。因此，他们在审讯中施加了额外的压力，试图获取真相。
The pressure became so overwhelming that at one point Marios broke down in tears, but at no point did either of the teenagers come any closer to making a confession. Police then took an unorthodox approach. Although it was illegal to place a wiretap on the home phones of minors, they did so anyway, covertly listening in on conversations between the two friends in the hopes of finding the evidence they needed. However, if Matias and Marios had any information, they were remaining tight-lipped. With no evidence, physical or otherwise, police reluctantly turned their focus away from the
压力变得如此巨大，以至于马里奥斯一度泪流满面，但两名青少年始终没有做出任何接近认罪的举动。警方随后采取了一种非正统的方法。尽管对未成年人的家庭电话进行窃听是非法的，但他们还是这样做了，秘密监听两个朋友之间的谈话，希望能找到他们需要的证据。然而，如果马蒂亚斯和马里奥斯有任何信息，他们也守口如瓶。由于没有任何物证或其他证据，警方不情愿地将注意力从
teens. They were still convinced that Robin and Christian knew something about Kevin's murder. They just couldn't figure out exactly what. As requested by police, their father, Vyner, had been taking note of anything the boys said about Kevin's death at home and reporting it back to the authorities. The brothers gave various accounts about how Kevin died and who was responsible. They switched between him being stabbed, kicked and pushed into the water. Sometimes the perpetrator was old, other times he was just a kid.
青少年身上移开。他们仍然确信罗宾和克里斯蒂安知道关于凯文谋杀案的一些事情。他们只是无法弄清楚到底是什么。应警方要求，他们的父亲维纳一直在记下男孩们在家中关于凯文之死所说的任何话，并将其报告给当局。兄弟俩对凯文是如何死的以及谁负责给出了各种说法。他们一会儿说他是被刺伤、踢伤，一会儿又说被推入水中。有时肇事者是成年人，有时又只是个孩子。
Their stories changed so constantly that police started to suspect they hadn't witnessed the murder at all. Instead, they believed the brothers had actually been involved with it. In all their changing stories, one detail remained consistent. Each telling centered around a floating jetty which was located just a couple of hundred metres from the boys' home. This seemed significant, however, the jetty was roughly 30 metres from the pallet where Kevin's body was found.
他们的故事变化如此频繁，以至于警察开始怀疑他们根本没有目睹谋杀。相反，他们认为兄弟俩实际上参与了其中。在他们所有不断变化的故事中，有一个细节保持一致。每次讲述都围绕着一个浮动码头，它距离男孩家只有几百米。这似乎很重要，然而，码头距离发现凯文尸体的托盘大约 30 米。
The two locations were separated by rough terrain, dense shrubbery and a stone wall. Kevin's body had no injuries consistent with being dragged across such an area. So if he really had been killed on the jetty, then how did he end up on the pallet? In mid-September, the boys' mother, Annika, reported that she'd been discussing the situation with Robin when he suddenly made an announcement. My brother did it. With this new information coming to light, investigators asked Robin if the person he saw kill Kevin was actually his big brother, Christian.
这两个地点被崎岖的地形、茂密的灌木丛和石墙隔开。凯文的尸体没有任何与被拖过此类区域相符的伤痕。所以如果他真的在码头上被杀，那他怎么会出现在托盘上？9 月中旬，男孩们的母亲安妮卡报告说，她正在和罗宾讨论这件事时，他突然宣布：“是我哥哥干的。”随着这一新信息的出现，调查人员问罗宾，他看到杀害凯文的人是否真的是他的哥哥克里斯蒂安。
Robin replied, Yes. Two months into the investigation, lead investigator Rolf Sundberry hired Sven Orker-Christensen, a professor of psychology at Stockholm University who had specialised knowledge in interrogation techniques and had worked with police on murder investigations in the past. Christensen had also conducted extensive research on the subject of repressed memories. He believed that certain memories can be lost when an individual experiences a traumatic event but that they can be retrieved from the subconscious later on. This psychogenic amnesia, as Christensen called it, was a defence mechanism aimed to protect
罗宾回答说：“是的。”调查进行两个月后，首席调查员罗尔夫·桑德伯里聘请了斯德哥尔摩大学心理学教授斯文·奥克-克里斯滕森（Sven Orker-Christensen），他拥有审讯技术的专业知识，过去曾与警方合作进行谋杀调查。克里斯滕森还对压抑记忆这一课题进行了广泛的研究。他认为，当一个人经历创伤事件时，某些记忆可能会丢失，但以后可以从潜意识中检索出来。正如克里斯滕森在其中一篇研究论文中所述，这种他称之为“心因性失忆症”的防御机制旨在保护
people from extreme emotions that surface during trauma, as stated in one of his research papers. To the same extent that we need mechanisms to identify and recognise unpleasant events, we also need mechanisms to forget unpleasant experiences. Christensen reviewed the interrogation reports from all of the children who had been questioned and immediately determined that Robin and Christian either knew exactly what happened to Kevin or had been involved in his death. They had likely repressed the memory and would eventually tell the truth but it could take some time, possibly several months.
人们免受创伤期间浮现的极端情绪的影响。正如我们需要识别和认识不愉快事件的机制一样，我们也需要忘记不愉快经历的机制。克里斯滕森审查了所有被询问儿童的审讯报告，并立即断定罗宾和克里斯蒂安要么确切地知道凯文发生了什么，要么参与了他的死亡。他们很可能压抑了记忆，最终会说出真相，但这可能需要一些时间，可能需要几个月。
The truth might not come out all at once but in dribs and draps. Christensen believed the most important thing the investigative team could do was make the boys feel safe enough to open up. When Weiner realised that his sons were now being treated as suspects, he couldn't take it anymore. The past two months had taken such an enormous toll on his mental health that, like his wife, he too was admitted to a psychiatric ward. Investigators visited Weiner in hospital to question him once again about the night that
真相可能不会一下子全部出来，而是零星地出现。克里斯滕森认为，调查小组能做的最重要的事情就是让男孩们感到足够安全，从而敞开心扉。当维纳意识到他的儿子们现在被视为嫌疑人时，他再也受不了了。过去两个月对他心理健康造成的巨大打击，使他像妻子一样，也被送进了精神病院。调查人员去医院探望维纳，再次询问他关于凯文被杀那晚的情况。
Kevin was killed. They wanted to know if he recalled his sons having wet clothing when they returned from playing outside that evening. Weiner said he couldn't remember for sure but admitted it was possible. The clothing Robin and Christian had been wearing on the night Kevin was killed was taken for analysis but the garments had already been washed so they held no clues. One night shortly after the police visit, Weiner suddenly remembered that on the night Kevin died, Christian had drawn a picture.
他们想知道他是否记得儿子们那天晚上从外面玩回来时衣服是湿的。维纳说他记不清了，但承认这是可能的。罗宾和克里斯蒂安在凯文被杀那晚穿的衣服被拿去分析，但衣服已经被洗过了，所以没有任何线索。在警察访问后不久的一个晚上，维纳突然想起在凯文死的那晚，克里斯蒂安画了一幅画。
It was of Kevin's body floating in the water near the jetty. By late October the interrogations had been ongoing for six weeks. During that time more than 1,300 interviews had been held with 482 individuals. After eliminating all other persons of interest, investigators pieced together the details provided by Robin and Christian and deduced the most likely scenario. The brothers had been playing a game with Kevin when things spiralled out of control. An argument likely broke out on the jetty and Christian had accidentally killed Kevin. The brothers had simply been so traumatized by the event that they'd blocked it out of
画的是凯文的尸体漂浮在码头附近的水中。到 10 月下旬，审讯已经进行了六周。在此期间，对 482 人进行了 1,300 多次采访。在排除了所有其他相关人员后，调查人员拼凑了罗宾和克里斯蒂安提供的细节，并推断出了最可能的情况。兄弟俩在和凯文玩游戏时，事情失控了。码头上可能发生了争执，克里斯蒂安意外杀死了凯文。兄弟俩只是被这件事吓坏了，以至于他们把这件事从
their memories, hence why they couldn't give investigators a straight answer about what happened or how Kevin's body got from the jetty to the pallet. The fact that Kevin died by a sharp object being pressed against his throat was still classified information. If the brothers revealed this detail, police felt satisfied that they could officially close the case. According to Professor Sven Orke Kristiansson, repressed memories could be revived by leading the children back to the scene where the traumatic event took place and recreating
他们的记忆中屏蔽了，这就是为什么他们不能给调查人员一个关于发生了什么或凯文的尸体是如何从码头到托盘的明确答案。凯文死于坚硬物体抵住喉咙的事实仍然是机密信息。如果兄弟俩透露了这个细节，警方认为他们可以正式结案。根据斯文·奥克-克里斯滕森教授的说法，压抑的记忆可以通过引导孩子们回到创伤事件发生的现场并重现
the same smells, sound and light. When investigators felt that the boys were close to making a breakthrough, Ingrid Harrison took Robin down to the jetty. She wore an earpiece so that Professor Kristiansson could guide her words. With them was a child-sized doll. Harrison encouraged Robin to use the doll to re-enact what happened to Kevin. She asked if he or Kristiansson did something to hurt Kevin. Robin replied, No.
相同的气味、声音和光线来恢复。当调查人员觉得男孩们快要取得突破时，英格丽德·霍雷森带着罗宾去了码头。她戴着耳机，以便克里斯滕森教授可以指导她的话。和他们在一起的还有一个儿童大小的玩偶。霍雷森鼓励罗宾用玩偶重演凯文身上发生的事情。她问他和克里斯滕森是否做了什么伤害凯文的事。罗宾回答说：“没有。”
Harrison encouraged Robin to play with the stick, but he ignored it, instead asking if he should push the doll into the water. Kristiansson was then brought to the jetty. Harrison encouraged him to use the doll to show where Kevin's injuries had occurred. Kristiansson shut down completely, saying, You can't know if you didn't see what happened. He eventually said that Robin pushed Kevin into the water after a fight on the jetty, but he still didn't make any mention of a stick or strangulation. Although the interrogation team were frustrated that they hadn't received the confession
霍雷森鼓励罗宾玩那根棍子，但他忽略了它，反而问他是否应该把玩偶推到水里。克里斯滕森随后被带到码头。霍雷森鼓励他用玩偶展示凯文的伤口是在哪里造成的。克里斯滕森完全崩溃了，说：“如果你没看到发生了什么，你就不可能知道。”他最终说罗宾在码头上打架后把凯文推到了水里，但他仍然没有提到棍子或勒死。尽管审讯小组对没有得到他们
they were hoping for, they were certain that the boys' memories were now bubbling away just below the surface and would soon be revealed. On October 26, it all became too much for Kristiansson. He broke down and finally admitted that Kevin wasn't killed on the floating jetty. According to Rov Sundbury's official report, the interrogation team left Sundbury alone to interview Kristian with Robin and Diva. This time, Kristian walked to the table where a map of the lake had been laid out. He picked up a pen and circled the area of reeds where Kevin's body was found.
所希望的供词感到沮丧，但他们确信男孩们的记忆现在正在表面之下涌动，很快就会显露出来。10 月 26 日，这一切对克里斯滕森来说太沉重了。他崩溃了，最终承认凯文不是在浮动码头上被杀的。根据罗夫·桑德伯里的官方报告，审讯小组让桑德伯里独自与克里斯蒂安、罗宾和迪娃（Diva）进行面谈。这一次，克里斯蒂安走到桌边，桌上铺着一张湖泊地图。他拿起一支笔，圈出了发现凯文尸体的芦苇丛区域。
He then indicated to Robin that it was okay to speak. Robin said that Kristian, Kevin and himself were playing in the soccer field when an argument broke out amongst them. The brothers began kicking and hitting Kevin, including in his groin area. They then chased Kevin down to the shore of the lake where the fight continued and Kevin somehow ended up on his back. Kristian then grabbed a stick and pushed it against Kevin's throat. When he let go, Robin knelt down and pinched Kevin in the throat, but he was already dead.
随后他示意罗宾可以说话了。罗宾说，克里斯蒂安、凯文和他自己当时正在足球场玩耍，期间他们发生了争执。兄弟俩开始踢打凯文，包括踢他的腹股沟部位。随后他们追着凯文到了湖边，打斗仍在继续，凯文不知怎么就仰面躺倒了。克里斯蒂安抓起一根棍子抵住凯文的喉咙。当他松手时，罗宾跪下来掐住凯文的喉咙，但那时凯文已经死了。
The brothers lifted Kevin up and dragged him onto a rock where they rested for a while before carrying him onto the pallet in the water. It was at this point that Kristian's clothing got wet. When Sundbury pointed out to Robin that this account differed from his most recent story, Robin replied, That was not true. Everything else is true. The following day, a press conference was held to announce that two young brothers had admitted
兄弟俩抬起凯文，把他拖到一块岩石上，休息了一会儿，然后把他抬到水里的托盘上。就在这时，克里斯蒂安的衣服湿了。当桑德伯里向罗宾指出这一说法与他最近的陈述不符时，罗宾回答说：“那不是真的。其他一切都是真的。”第二天，新闻发布会上宣布，两名年幼的兄弟承认
to killing five-year-old Kevin Jelmeson. It was the first time in modern Swedish history that a child had been blamed for killing another child and the authorities knew they had to choose their words carefully. Instead of labelling it a murder, they announced that Kevin's death was the result of a game that had gotten out of hand. Due to the age of those responsible, there would be no trial and their identities would not be revealed. Sundbury urged,
杀害了五岁的凯文·耶尔梅森。这是瑞典现代史上第一次有儿童被指控杀害另一名儿童，当局知道他们必须谨慎措辞。他们没有将其定性为谋杀，而是宣布凯文的死是一场失控的游戏的结果。由于肇事者年龄尚小，他们不会受到审判，身份也不会被公开。桑德伯里敦促道：
This investigation only involves victims. I therefore implore the media to show restraint and consideration towards Kevin's relatives, as well as the children involved and their relatives. Despite their names being suppressed, there was no hiding Robin and Kristian's identities from their fellow residents of Avika. The community wanted nothing to do with the boys or their family, and some people wanted revenge. It wasn't safe for the family to return home, so Robin, Kristian, Vyna and Eva were moved
“这次调查只涉及受害者。因此，我恳请媒体对凯文的亲属，以及涉事儿童及其亲属表现出克制和体谅。”尽管他们的名字被隐去，但罗宾和克里斯蒂安的身份在阿维卡（Arvika）的居民中还是无法隐藏。社区不想与这两个男孩或他们的家庭有任何瓜葛，有些人甚至想要报复。这对家庭回家的路不再安全，于是罗宾、克里斯蒂安、维娜和伊娃被转移到
to a treatment facility outside of town, while authorities figured out the next steps. The boys' mother, Annika, was relocated nearby, but she was only allowed to see her son's for scheduled visits. A team of 11 staff were assigned to help the family process what had happened. Robin and Kristian couldn't grasp the situation and kept asking when they'd be going home. Robin continuously asked when he'd be able to see his bike again. Speaking about the case, Rolf Sundbury later commented, After all the conversations we had with children, I realized that children are fully aware of
镇外的一家治疗机构，同时当局在研究下一步措施。男孩们的母亲安妮卡被安置在附近，但她只被允许在预定的探视时间见她的儿子。一个由11名工作人员组成的团队被指派帮助这个家庭处理所发生的一切。罗宾和克里斯蒂安无法理解这种情况，一直问他们什么时候能回家。罗宾不断地问他什么时候能再见到他的自行车。谈到这个案件时，罗尔夫·桑德伯里后来评论道：“在与孩子们进行了所有交谈后，我意识到孩子们完全清楚
their actions. In the Kevin case, the boys knew they weren't playing a game. They knew that if they did something in a certain way, it could lead to death. Robin and Kristian were both subject to various tests, including MRIs and EEGs, to check for any brain damage or abnormalities. Authorities were interested in figuring out why the brothers had killed Kevin and whether they presented a danger in the future. In April of 1999, a special program titled Project Staircase was developed to help Kristian
他们的行为。”在凯文案中，男孩们知道他们不是在玩游戏。他们知道，如果他们以某种方式做某事，可能会导致死亡。罗宾和克里斯蒂安都接受了各种检查，包括核磁共振和脑电图，以检查是否有脑损伤或异常。当局有兴趣弄清楚兄弟俩为什么要杀害凯文，以及他们未来是否构成危险。1999年4月，一个名为“楼梯计划”的特别项目被开发出来，旨在帮助克里斯蒂安
and Robin come to terms with what they'd done and to help integrate them back into society. As part of Project Staircase, the boys would move with Vina and Eva into an apartment within a treatment facility, while a team of assistants would live in the apartment above. The assistants would monitor the family's movements from 9am to 8pm, taking note of everything from their daily activities to their interactions to the boys' toilet breaks. Robin and Kristian would undergo daily therapy sessions where they'd be asked how they felt about Kevin's death. The aim was to help them process what had happened without fear of judgment or rejection.
和罗宾接受他们所做的事情，并帮助他们重新融入社会。作为“楼梯计划”的一部分，男孩们将与维娜和伊娃搬进治疗机构内的一间公寓，而一组助理将住在楼上的公寓里。助理们会从早上9点到晚上8点监控这家人的动向，记录从他们的日常活动、互动到男孩们上厕所休息的一切。罗宾和克里斯蒂安将接受每日治疗，询问他们对凯文之死的感受。目的是帮助他们在没有评判或拒绝恐惧的情况下处理所发生的事情。
They'd soon be allowed to return to school on two conditions. An assistant would accompany them in the classroom every day, and they weren't allowed to tell any of their classmates about Kevin or their involvement in his death. Five months into Project Staircase, Kristian was in his daily therapy session when he suddenly made a revelation. The reason he had taken so long to confess was because his father had instructed him and Robin not to tell anyone how Kevin had died. The authorities were stunned.
他们很快被允许在两个条件下重返学校。一名助理每天会陪同他们进入教室，而且他们不被允许告诉任何同学关于凯文或他们参与其死亡的事情。在“楼梯计划”进行五个月后，克里斯蒂安在一次日常治疗中突然透露了一个秘密。他之所以花了这么长时间才坦白，是因为他的父亲曾指示他和罗宾不要告诉任何人凯文是怎么死的。当局感到震惊。
From early on, they had suspected that Vina might have been covering something up and that he may have been the one who carried Kevin's body from the jetty to the pallet. Kristian's revelation only strengthened their belief. Deeming Vina unfit to be a parent, Robin and Kristian were taken out of the clinic and temporarily put into their mother's custody. Vina adamantly denied having any involvement in Kevin's death or telling the boys to lie about their involvement. The authorities decided the brothers would be best placed in foster care and set about
从很早开始，他们就怀疑维娜可能隐瞒了什么，并且他可能是那个将凯文的尸体从码头搬到托盘上的人。克里斯蒂安的揭露加强了他们的信念。由于认为维娜不适合做父亲，罗宾和克里斯蒂安被带离诊所，暂时交由他们的母亲监护。维娜坚决否认参与了凯文的死亡，也否认告诉男孩们撒谎掩盖他们的参与。当局决定最好将兄弟俩安置在寄养家庭，并着手
finding suitable placements. However, when prospective families found out who Robin and Kristian were, they wanted nothing to do with them. Nobody felt safe having a child killer in their homes. Eventually, the decision was made. Kristian would live with his mother while Robin would remain with Eva and Vina. The brothers could see one another on weekends. In early 2000, projects staircase officially disbanded and the families were free to live
寻找合适的安置点。然而，当潜在的家庭发现罗宾和克里斯蒂安是谁时，他们不想与他们有任何瓜葛。没有人觉得家里有一个杀人犯是安全的。最终，决定做出了。克里斯蒂安将与他的母亲住在一起，而罗宾将与伊娃和维娜住在一起。兄弟俩可以在周末见面。2000年初，“楼梯计划”正式解散，这些家庭第一次在一年多来
without daily supervision for the first time in over a year. However, they still had to abide by strict rules. Under no circumstances was anyone to reveal their involvement with the Kevin case. If an outsider ever found out their secret, a crisis plan was put in place. The boys were also forbidden from returning to Arvika until they turned 18, but at this point it didn't matter anyway. None of their friends wanted anything to do with them. Although neither brother initially had any recollection of the event, they'd believed
无需每日监督。然而，他们仍然必须遵守严格的规定。在任何情况下，任何人都不得透露他们与凯文案的关联。如果外人发现了他们的秘密，就会启动危机计划。男孩们也被禁止在18岁之前回到阿维卡，但此时这已经无关紧要了。他们以前的朋友都不想和他们有任何瓜葛。虽然兄弟俩最初对这件事都没有任何记忆，但他们相信
it was possible that they'd blocked the memories out, as investigators said. As years began to pass, the whole situation remained shrouded in mystery. Kristian and Robin weren't allowed to talk about it with friends, and their parents seemed eager to put it all behind them and move forward. But every now and then, when life felt normal again, an unexpected abusive message would find its way into their letterbox or email accounts to remind them of their dark past. By the time Robin was 10, his niggling concerns had developed into full-blown doubt that he was capable of hurting his best friend.
正如调查人员所说，他们可能已经封锁了这些记忆。随着岁月的流逝，整个情况仍然笼罩在神秘之中。克里斯蒂安和罗宾不被允许与朋友谈论这件事，他们的父母似乎急于把这一切抛在脑后，继续前进。但每隔一段时间，当生活感觉恢复正常时，一条意想不到的辱骂信息就会出现在他们的信箱或电子邮件账户中，提醒他们黑暗的过去。到罗宾10岁时，他内心隐隐的担忧已经演变成对自己是否有能力伤害最好的朋友的彻底怀疑。
It just didn't feel possible that he could have absolutely no memory of such a significant event. He wondered if he'd simply witnessed the crime and gotten his stories mixed up. At the same time, he was plagued by the question, what if it was me? Over the next few years, Robin started doing his own research about the case, using the internet to uncover any information he could get his hands on. The more he learned, the more he felt he couldn't be responsible. If he was capable of such horrific behavior, he didn't want to live.
他觉得他不可能对如此重大的事件完全没有记忆。他怀疑自己是否只是目睹了犯罪，然后把故事搞混了。与此同时，他被一个问题困扰着：如果是我呢？在接下来的几年里，罗宾开始自己研究这个案件，利用互联网挖掘他能找到的任何信息。他了解得越多，就越觉得他不可能是肇事者。如果他有能力做出如此可怕的行为，他就不想活了。
Robin's mental health began to suffer, and he considered suicide. In contrast, Kristian didn't want to dwell on the past. He tried not to think about Kevin's death, but there were some things he couldn't avoid. Ever since the police interrogations had begun, Kristian's sleep had suffered hugely. He became so riddled with anxiety that he tossed and turned all night and could never fully relax. He was afraid of the dark and would wake up in a panic several times each night. According to the book The Story of the Kevin Case, one night not long after his confession,
罗宾的心理健康开始恶化，他考虑过自杀。相比之下，克里斯蒂安不想沉湎于过去。他尽量不去想凯文的死，但有些事情是他无法避免的。自从警方审讯开始以来，克里斯蒂安的睡眠受到了极大的影响。他变得焦虑不安，整晚辗转反侧，无法完全放松。他害怕黑暗，每晚都会惊恐地醒来好几次。根据《凯文案的故事》一书，在他坦白后不久的一个晚上，
a forlorn Kristian summoned his mother to the clinic where he was being housed because he had something he wanted to tell her. When she arrived, he said, I know nothing about Kevin. I wasn't there. When Anika reasoned that that hadn't been what he'd told the police, Kristian responded. But I just invented everything. Concerned, Anika reported this to the police, but they assured her that her sons had been telling the truth.
一个绝望的克里斯蒂安把他的母亲叫到他所住的诊所，因为他有话要告诉她。当她到达时，他说：“我对凯文一无所知。我不在那里。”当安妮卡辩解说那不是他告诉警察的话时，克里斯蒂安回答说：“但我只是编造了一切。”安妮卡感到担忧，向警方报告了此事，但他们向她保证，她的儿子们说的是实话。
While the interrogation reports were confidential and they couldn't reveal exactly what was said, the police confirmed that Kristian and Robin had provided descriptions of Kevin's death that only those responsible could know. A couple of years later in 2001, the boys' parents asked to see the transcripts of the interrogations after one senior investigator contacted them to raise questions about the way things were handled. Lead investigator Rolf Sundberry refused on the grounds that the investigation was classified and the parents didn't push any further.
虽然审讯报告是保密的，他们无法透露具体说了什么，但警方证实，克里斯蒂安和罗宾提供的关于凯文死亡的描述只有肇事者才知道。几年后的2001年，在一位高级调查员联系他们并对处理方式提出质疑后，男孩们的父母要求查看审讯记录。首席调查员罗尔夫·桑德伯里以调查属于机密为由拒绝了，父母们也没有再追究。
On the outset, they'd felt completely out of depth when dealing with the authorities. They had fully trusted the process and accepted that the necessary steps had to be taken to find Kevin's killer, even if it meant a few difficult months for Robin and Kristian. Robin eventually fell in love with a woman named Mimi, and when he was 20 years old, the two welcomed a baby boy. However, the secret about his past continued to haunt him. Robin was under strict instructions not to tell Mimi about the Kevin case, and their relationship suffered as a result.
起初，他们在与当局打交道时感到完全不知所措。他们完全信任这个过程，并接受了为了找到凯文的杀手必须采取必要步骤的事实，即使这意味着罗宾和克里斯蒂安要经历几个困难的月份。罗宾最终爱上了一个名叫米米的女人，当他20岁时，两人迎来了一个男婴。然而，关于他过去的秘密继续困扰着他。罗宾受到严格指示，不得告诉米米关于凯文案的事，结果他们的关系受到了影响。
By the time their son was three months old, Robin and Mimi broke up, with Robin given full custody. Kristian had done his best to push the Kevin case to the back of his mind, but he found it impossible to live a normal life with such a huge secret in his past. By the time he was in his early 20s, the thought occurred to him for the first time. What if he didn't do it? Kristian was still in close contact with the child psychologist Bent Joran Jornson, who had been seeing ever since the police interrogations.
当他们的儿子三个月大时，罗宾和米米分手了，罗宾获得了完全监护权。克里斯蒂安尽了最大努力把凯文案抛在脑后，但他发现带着过去这样一个巨大的秘密过正常生活是不可能的。当他20出头时，他第一次产生了一个想法：如果不是他做的呢？克里斯蒂安仍然与儿童心理学家本特·约兰·约恩森保持密切联系，自警方审讯以来他一直都在看这位心理学家。
He voiced his concerns to Jornson, but he assured him he could put his mind at ease. There was no doubt that Kristian and Robin were responsible. Professor Richard Sherbury specialised in neuroscience at Umeå University in northern Sweden, and he had a particular fascination with forensic psychology. In 2010, Professor Sherbury became involved with the high-profile case that shocked Sweden to the core. Sturra Berival, formerly known as Thomas Quick, was a Swedish man who confessed to committing more than 30 murders and cannibalising several of his victims.
他向约恩森表达了他的担忧，但他向他保证他可以放心。毫无疑问，克里斯蒂安和罗宾是肇事者。理查德·谢尔伯里教授是瑞典北部于默奥大学的神经科学专家，他对法医心理学有着特殊的迷恋。2010年，谢尔伯里教授参与了这起震惊瑞典全国的高调案件。斯图拉·贝里瓦尔（Sture Bergwall），原名托马斯·奎克（Thomas Quick），是一名瑞典男子，他承认犯下了30多起谋杀案，并食用了几名受害者。
He was ultimately convicted for eight of the murders and sentenced to psychiatric confinement. However, the confessions were made while Berival was undergoing psychiatric treatment in a mental health facility, and they only came about after a team of psychiatrists used recovered memory therapy to extract vague information from a heavily medicated Berival that could loosely tie him to the crimes. In the absence of any concrete evidence, the credibility of his confessions was hotly disputed, and when Berival retracted all of his confessions in 2008, there was no ground for the convictions to stand on.
他最终因八起谋杀案被定罪并被判处精神病监禁。然而，这些供词是在贝里瓦尔在精神卫生机构接受精神治疗时做出的，而且只有在精神科医生团队使用恢复记忆疗法从服用大量药物的贝里瓦尔那里提取出可以勉强将他与犯罪联系起来的模糊信息后才出现。在缺乏任何具体证据的情况下，他供词的可信度受到了激烈质疑，当贝里瓦尔在2008年撤回所有供词时，定罪的基础就不复存在了。
Professor Sherbury was part of the team that criticised the memory techniques used in Berival's case, and all eight of his convictions were ultimately quashed. It was deduced that the psychiatric team had essentially used leading questions to coerce Berival into believing that he remembered certain details about the crimes, when in reality he had no involvement whatsoever. Berival ultimately admitted he had lied about his involvement in the crimes because he enjoyed the attention, and because the medication he was on enabled him to confidently create the false stories.
谢尔伯里教授是批评贝里瓦尔案中所用记忆技术的团队成员之一，他所有的八项定罪最终都被撤销。据推断，精神科团队本质上使用了诱导性问题来强迫贝里瓦尔相信他记得犯罪的某些细节，而实际上他根本没有参与。贝里瓦尔最终承认他撒谎说自己参与了这些犯罪，因为他喜欢这种关注，而且他服用的药物使他能够自信地编造虚假故事。
In 2013, Sherbury began looking through the Kevin case, and noticed there were distinct similarities between it and the Thomas Quick case. Not only did both cases rely strongly on repressed memories, but both investigations had been guided by the same memory specialist, Professor Sven Ocke Christensen. While Christensen's work on repressed memories had seemed groundbreaking at the time, this methodology had since come under fire. Research had revealed that the so-called techniques used by therapists to recover repressed memories also had the potential to create false memories of experiences that never happened.
2013年，谢尔伯里开始审视凯文案，并注意到它与托马斯·奎克案之间存在明显的相似之处。这两个案件不仅严重依赖压抑的记忆，而且两项调查都由同一位记忆专家斯文·奥克·克里斯滕森教授指导。虽然克里斯滕森关于压抑记忆的工作在当时似乎具有开创性，但这种方法论此后受到了抨击。研究表明，治疗师用来恢复压抑记忆的所谓技术也有可能创造出从未发生过的经历的虚假记忆。
Professor Sherbury started reading about the techniques used to solve Kevin Yulmerson's murder and was immediately suspicious. There was simply no scientific evidence to support the interrogation techniques used against Robin and Christian. Research had also taught him that having multiple long interrogations with children can be dangerous. The harder children are pressed, the more likely they are to tell police what they think they want to hear. Professor Sherbury couldn't help but wonder, what if their brothers hadn't had anything
谢尔伯里教授开始阅读关于解决凯文·耶尔梅森谋杀案所用技术的内容，并立即产生了怀疑。根本没有任何科学证据支持针对罗宾和克里斯蒂安的审讯技术。研究还告诉他，对儿童进行多次长时间的审讯可能是危险的。孩子们被逼得越紧，他们就越有可能告诉警察他们认为警察想听的话。谢尔伯里教授不禁想，如果兄弟俩根本没有参与凯文的死亡呢？
to do with Kevin's death after all? Professor Sherbury contacted Don Yusufsen, a respected journalist whom he'd worked with on the Thomas Quick case, and told him about his suspicions. Yusufsen wasted no time in looking into the Kevin case himself. He immediately shared Professor Sherbury's concerns that a severe miscarriage of justice might have taken place. Christian and Robin's family had a strict no-media rule and they were near impossible to get in contact with.
谢尔伯里教授联系了唐·尤素夫森，一位他在托马斯·奎克案中合作过的受人尊敬的记者，并告诉了他自己的怀疑。尤素夫森毫不浪费时间，亲自调查凯文案。他立即分享了谢尔伯里教授的担忧，即可能发生了严重的司法不公。克里斯蒂安和罗宾的家庭有严格的“不接触媒体”规定，几乎不可能与他们取得联系。
Don Yusufsen persisted for five months and eventually they agreed to speak with him. When the family learned of his intentions to make a documentary about the case, they were hesitant. If Yusufsen's suspicions were wrong and investigators had acted entirely above board, the family risked revealing their true identities after 17 years of secrecy. All their hard work would be undone and Christian and Robin would be publicly outed as child killers. Yusufsen made them a promise.
唐·尤素夫森坚持了五个月，最终他们同意与他交谈。当家人得知他打算制作一部关于此案的纪录片时，他们犹豫了。如果尤素夫森的怀疑是错误的，而调查人员的行为完全合规，那么这个家庭在保守了17年的秘密后，就有可能暴露他们的真实身份。他们所有的努力都将付诸东流，克里斯蒂安和罗宾将被公开为杀人犯。尤素夫森向他们做出了一个承诺。
If he and his team couldn't find any evidence to support their theory of a botched investigation, they'd forget about the documentary entirely. The family agreed on the condition that they didn't want updates until Yusufsen's team had completed their research. Because the Kevin case was classified, the documentary crew had to use various sources to get their hands on the preliminary investigation. They eventually gained access to interrogation transcripts as well as some video footage of the interrogations.
如果他和他的团队找不到任何证据来支持他们关于调查拙劣的理论，他们就会完全忘记这部纪录片。家人同意了，条件是他们不想在尤素夫森的团队完成研究之前得到任何更新。由于凯文案是机密的，纪录片摄制组必须使用各种来源来获取初步调查资料。他们最终获得了审讯记录以及一些审讯的视频片段。
The more they uncovered, the more shocked they became. It was immediately clear that the interrogation team had acted unethically. The European Convention stipulates that children should only be interrogated once and never for a long period of time. Children and Christian were interrogated a total of 30 times, with some interrogations lasting over four and a half hours. Their parents were rarely present, even when the boys became visibly distressed. During the interrogations, the brothers had singled out a total of nine different perpetrators
他们揭露得越多，就越感到震惊。调查团队行为不道德这一点立即显现出来。《欧洲公约》规定，儿童只能接受一次审讯，且绝不能长时间审讯。克里斯蒂安和罗宾总共接受了30次审讯，有些审讯持续了四个半小时以上。他们的父母很少在场，即使在男孩们明显感到痛苦时也是如此。在审讯过程中，兄弟俩总共指出了九名不同的肇事者，
and mentioned at least seven different ways that Kevin had died. They rarely repeated the same story twice. Up until the very last interrogations, at no point did either of the boys mention the pallet where Kevin was found or the correct method of Kevin's death. It was only when the interrogation team fed them leading questions that they were able to provide the details the investigators seemed so desperate to hear. In fact, the majority of the most damning statements made by the brothers had been the result of leading questions.
并提到了至少七种凯文死亡的方式。他们很少重复同一个故事两次。直到最后几次审讯，男孩们都没有提到发现凯文的托盘或凯文死亡的正确方法。只有当审讯团队向他们提出诱导性问题时，他们才能够提供调查人员似乎非常渴望听到的细节。事实上，兄弟俩做出的大多数最令人震惊的陈述都是诱导性问题的结果。
One of the main reasons that Robin and Christian had been considered suspects was that Robin had responded yes when Sundbury asked if his older brother was the one who killed Kevin. After being shocked by this response, Sundbury had proceeded to ask Robin 15 more times whether he saw Christian kill Kevin. Of those 15 times, Robin replied yes eight times, but seven times he said no. It was clear from the interrogation reports and videos that investigators became increasingly frustrated as time went by. In the final stages of the investigation, the boys had been taken to the jetty with
罗宾和克里斯蒂安被视为嫌疑人的主要原因之一是，当桑德伯里问他的哥哥是否是杀害凯文的人时，罗宾回答了“是”。在对这个回答感到震惊后，桑德伯里继续问了罗宾15次他是否看到克里斯蒂安杀害了凯文。在这15次中，罗宾回答了8次“是”，但有7次他说“不”。从审讯报告和视频中可以清楚地看出，随着时间的推移，调查人员变得越来越沮丧。在调查的最后阶段，男孩们被带到码头，
a life-sized doll in the hopes their so-called repressed memories would resurface. When a visibly upset Christian had claimed that he didn't know how Kevin's injuries had occurred, Ingrid Harrison had pushed him saying, but you did see because you were here. It's you who knows because you were here. Christian, what did you do to Kevin? In the subsequent final interrogations, investigators not only intensified their use of leading questions, but blatantly fed the brother's information in order to extract a confession. Ingrid Harrison was receiving directions from the rest of the team in her earpiece.
带着一个真人大小的玩偶，希望他们所谓的压抑记忆能浮现出来。当明显心烦意乱的克里斯蒂安声称他不知道凯文的伤是怎么造成的时，英格丽德·哈里森逼问他说：“但你确实看到了，因为你在这里。是你，因为你在这里，所以你知道。克里斯蒂安，你对凯文做了什么？”在随后的最后审讯中，调查人员不仅加强了诱导性问题的使用，而且公然向兄弟俩提供信息以获取供词。英格丽德·哈里森在耳机里接收着团队其他成员的指示。
She stopped beating around the bush and straight out told Robin where Kevin's body was found and that he had a bruise on his neck. They even drew him pictures. From there, she proceeded to ask Robin more than a hundred times how the injuries occurred on Kevin's neck. Robin repeatedly said he didn't know. Eventually, with Harrison continuously pressuring him to speak about Kevin's neck, Robin finally said that Christian pinched Kevin on the throat.
她不再拐弯抹角，直接告诉罗宾凯文的尸体是在哪里发现的，以及他的脖子上有一块淤青。他们甚至给他画了画。从那里，她继续问罗宾一百多次伤口是如何在凯文的脖子上造成的。罗宾反复说他不知道。最终，在哈里森不断向他施压要求谈论凯文的脖子时，罗宾终于说克里斯蒂安掐了凯文的喉咙。
At no point did he mention helping carry Kevin's body to the pallet. Despite Harrison literally telling him how and where Kevin had died, Robin seemed incapable of providing this information. The same technique was then used on Christian. Over four and a half hours of questioning, he became increasingly distressed. He cried and repeatedly asked for his mother. All up, he asked 61 times for the questioning to stop. Instead, the interrogators told him he could only see his mother if he admitted what happened
他从未提到帮助搬运凯文的尸体到托盘上。尽管哈里森实际上告诉了他凯文是如何以及在哪里死亡的，但罗宾似乎无法提供这些信息。同样的技术随后被用在克里斯蒂安身上。在四个半小时的审讯中，他变得越来越痛苦。他哭了，反复要求见他的母亲。总共，他要求停止审讯61次。相反，审讯人员告诉他，只有承认凯文发生了什么，他才能见到他的母亲。
to Kevin. At this point, it was clear that he'd say anything if it meant he could leave, but he still couldn't provide the information they were so obviously hoping to hear. Instead, detectives showed Christian a photo map of the lake and blatantly pointed out the area where Kevin's body was found. One detective asked, did you carry him there? Now realizing what they wanted him to say, Christian said yes. However, he was still unable to explain how.
此时，很明显，如果这意味着他可以离开，他会说任何话，但他仍然无法提供他们如此明显希望听到的信息。相反，侦探向克里斯蒂安展示了一张湖泊的照片地图，并公然指出了发现凯文尸体的区域。一名侦探问：“你把他搬到那里了吗？”现在意识到他们想要他说什么，克里斯蒂安说了“是”。然而，他仍然无法解释是如何做到的。
For the investigative team, it didn't seem to matter. That evening, lead investigator Rolf Sundberg interviewed the brothers and then wrote an official report declaring that they had made a full confession. Interestingly, no other investigator was present during this significant interview, and it was the only time during the entire investigation that Sundberg filed an official report. Robin and Christian were both interviewed again the following morning, but this time neither of them repeated the confession they'd supposedly given the previous day. The reality was, there wasn't a single piece of evidence to tie Robin and Christian to
对于调查团队来说，这似乎并不重要。那天晚上，首席调查员罗尔夫·桑德伯里采访了兄弟俩，然后写了一份正式报告，宣布他们已经做出了全面供词。有趣的是，在这次重要的采访中没有其他调查人员在场，这是桑德伯里在整个调查过程中唯一一次提交正式报告。罗宾和克里斯蒂安在第二天早上再次接受了采访，但这一次他们都没有重复前一天所谓的供词。事实是，没有任何证据将罗宾和克里斯蒂安与
the crime. Their finger and hand prints didn't match those found on the stick believed to be the murder weapon. In fact, there was no evidence that the stick was the murder weapon at all. He had witnessed the brothers at the scene of the crime, nor had they provided any insider information until the interrogation team spoon fed it to them. Forensic specialists also didn't think it was possible that the brothers could have moved Kevin from the jetty to the pallet, nor had they ever provided any explanation of
犯罪联系起来。他们的指纹和手印与在被认为是凶器的棍子上发现的指纹不匹配。事实上，没有任何证据表明那根棍子就是凶器。没有人目睹兄弟俩在犯罪现场，他们也没有提供任何内部信息，直到审讯团队把信息喂给他们。法医专家也不认为兄弟俩有可能把凯文从码头搬到托盘上，他们也从未提供过任何关于
how they managed to do so. At the time of the investigation, the authorities didn't think that Robin and Christian needed illegal assistance, because they weren't able to be prosecuted due to their age. No one ever told the boys' parents about their right to a lawyer, and they had never thought to ask. Had a defense lawyer been brought in, they would never have allowed the brothers to be interrogated for so long, or so many times. Furthermore, a crucial detail would have never slipped through the cracks.
他们是如何做到这一点的解释。在调查时，当局认为罗宾和克里斯蒂安不需要法律援助，因为他们因年龄原因无法被起诉。没有人告诉男孩们的父母他们有权聘请律师，他们也从未想过要问。如果请了辩护律师，他们绝不会允许兄弟俩被审讯这么久，或这么多次。此外，一个关键细节绝不会被遗漏。
At the time of Kevin's death, the Dalyan family were close with another family called the Grorns, who had children similar in age to Robin and Christian. The two families thought it would be nice to spend the last day of summer vacation together. On Sunday, August 16, 1998, the Grorns arrived at the Dalyan's house mid-afternoon. While the adults chatted inside, the three Grorn children played outside with Robin and Christian. As the eldest of the group, the Grorns' 10-year-old was put in charge and told to keep an eye on the younger kids.
在凯文去世时，达利安一家与另一个叫格隆的家庭关系密切，他们有与罗宾和克里斯蒂安年龄相仿的孩子。两家人认为一起度过暑假的最后一天会很不错。1998年8月16日星期日，格隆一家在下午中旬到达达利安家。当大人们在里面聊天时，三个格隆家的孩子在外面和罗宾、克里斯蒂安一起玩。作为这群孩子中最大的，格隆家10岁的孩子被委以重任，被告知要看好年幼的孩子。
When police later questioned him, he was unwaveringly adamant that Robin or Christian never left his sight for any period of time. Likewise, his mother had been keeping a close eye on the children from the window, and she confirmed that none of them ever strayed from view. After dinner, the two families left to go fishing at around 6pm. Christian rode in the car with the Grorn family, who stopped at a gas station just outside of Drvick to put petrol in their car. This was corroborated by receipts as well as the gas station owner.
当警察后来审问他时，他坚定不移地坚持认为罗宾或克里斯蒂安从未离开过他的视线。同样，他的母亲一直从窗户密切注视着孩子们，她证实他们中没有人离开过视线。晚饭后，两家人在晚上6点左右出发去钓鱼。克里斯蒂安和格隆一家坐车，他们在德维克（Drvik）外的一个加油站停下来加油。这一点得到了收据以及加油站老板的证实。
During the fishing trip, all the children remained within view of the parents at all times. Police had been aware of this alibi since the early days of the investigation. In fact, they'd interviewed the Grorns a total of 14 times, and they always told the same story. Police never told Vyner and Eva that their alibi had been verified, and the Grorn family stopped speaking to them in the wake of Kevin's death. This led to the boys' parents questioning their own recollection of that evening and
在钓鱼期间，所有的孩子始终都在父母的视线范围内。警方从调查初期就知道了这个不在场证明。事实上，他们总共采访了格隆一家14次，他们总是说同样的故事。警察从未告诉维娜和伊娃他们的不在场证明已经得到核实，而格隆一家在凯文死后就停止与他们交谈。这导致男孩们的父母质疑他们自己对那天晚上的回忆，并
wondering whether the boys had indeed snuck off at some point without their knowledge. The suspicion against the brothers had been fueled by Vyner and Eva's admission that the boys may have had wet clothes on the night that Kevin had died, and that they may have admitted to seeing Kevin be killed on the night that had happened. However, these admissions had been made while Eva and Vyner were heavily medicated and receiving treatment at a psychiatric facility. Police had persisted in asking probing questions despite knowing full well that they were taking sedatives and suffering immense stress.
怀疑男孩们是否真的在他们不知情的情况下溜走了。对兄弟俩的怀疑是由维娜和伊娃承认男孩们在凯文去世的那天晚上可能穿了湿衣服，以及他们可能承认在事情发生的那天晚上看到凯文被杀而助长的。然而，这些承认是在伊娃和维娜服用大量药物并在精神病院接受治疗时做出的。尽管明知他们正在服用镇静剂并承受着巨大的压力，警察仍坚持提出探究性问题。
Not only had investigators acted unethically and overlooked a crucial alibi, they'd been quick to rule out a potential person of interest. On May 7, 1999, just nine months after Kevin's death, a 50-year-old Dr. Vick resident was walking through the playground near the lake when they came upon a horrifying incident. A three-year-old boy was being raped in the sand pit. The witness scared the perpetrator off but managed to catch a good glimpse of him as he fled the scene. It was Felix, the same 13-year-old boy who had been spotted with Kevin Jolmeson on the
调查人员不仅行为不道德并忽略了一个关键的不在场证明，他们还很快排除了一个潜在的利益相关者。1999年5月7日，就在凯文去世九个月后，一名50岁的德维克居民在湖边的操场上行走时，目睹了一起可怕的事件。一个三岁的男孩在沙坑里被强奸。目击者吓跑了肇事者，但在他逃离现场时看清了他的样子。那是菲利克斯，那个在凯文·耶尔梅森被杀的那天晚上
night that he was killed. Felix fled across the nearby border to Norway but soon returned to Dr. Vick and turned himself in. He admitted to the crime but, given his age, he was sent to a treatment facility before returning to regular schooling. Three years later, he was speaking to a classmate about the rape when he allegedly confessed, I have done worse things than that. According to the book The Story of the Kevin Case, Felix's family lived in the same apartment
被发现与他在一起的13岁男孩。菲利克斯逃过了附近的边境进入挪威，但很快回到德维克并自首。他承认了罪行，但考虑到他的年龄，他被送往治疗机构，然后才回到常规学校。三年后，他在与同学谈论强奸案时据称承认：“我做过比那更糟糕的事情。”根据《凯文案的故事》一书，菲利克斯的家人住在与凯文的母亲特里亚斯（Therias）相同的公寓
complex as Kevin's mother, Therias. Just six days after Kevin was killed, Felix's mother suffered a heart attack. Therias had rushed to help provide CPR and paramedics were able to revive her. But when Therias heard that Felix had sexually assaulted a young child, she immediately became suspicious. Was it possible that Felix's mother knew more about Kevin's death than she wanted to admit and had that caused her heart attack? There were several factors that made Felix appear suspect.
大楼里。在凯文被杀仅六天后，菲利克斯的母亲心脏病发作。特里亚斯冲过去帮忙进行心肺复苏，医护人员成功救活了她。但当特里亚斯听说菲利克斯性侵了一名幼童时，她立即产生了怀疑。菲利克斯的母亲是否知道更多关于凯文死亡的事情，而这导致了她的心脏病发作？有几个因素使菲利克斯看起来很可疑。
Not only was he one of the last people seen with Kevin but he'd also been the one who told the other children where they could find Kevin's shoes and socks behind the shed. Felix had denied being with Kevin on the night of his death, despite multiple witnesses placing the two of them together. He told police that he'd wrote around town for a while before visiting the library, then writing home. However, had the police bothered to double check this alibi, they would have discovered that the library was actually closed on Sundays.
他不仅是最后见到凯文的人之一，而且还是他告诉其他孩子可以在棚子后面找到凯文的鞋子和袜子的。菲利克斯否认在凯文去世的那天晚上与他在一起，尽管有多名目击者将他们两人放在一起。他告诉警察，他在城里骑了一会儿车，然后去了图书馆，然后骑车回家。然而，如果警察费心去核实这个不在场证明，他们会发现图书馆实际上在周日是关闭的。
Furthermore, no witnesses had seen Felix writing around town as he described. Before Felix arrived in Dottovik, he spent time in a refugee camp after fleeing war in his home country. His childhood had been marred by traumatic events and he also had an intellectual disability. After being revealed as a child rapist, many Dottovik residents began to wonder if he could have been the real perpetrator of Kevin's death. The combined factors seemed way too coincidental and it was possible that the police could have written Felix off to avoid igniting xenophobia amongst Swedish citizens.
此外，没有目击者看到菲利克斯像他描述的那样在城里骑车。在到达多托维克（Dottovik）之前，菲利克斯在逃离家乡的战争后在难民营待过一段时间。他的童年被创伤性事件所破坏，他还有智力障碍。在被揭露为儿童强奸犯后，许多多托维克居民开始怀疑他是否可能是凯文死亡的真正肇事者。这些综合因素看起来太巧合了，警察有可能为了避免在瑞典公民中煽动仇外心理而排除了菲利克斯。
Kevin's family voiced their concerns to the authorities but were advised that Kevin's case was closed and that was that. Robin and Christian's mother also found it curious that Felix wasn't looked into further. She contacted both the police and the media to explore the possible connection but it seemed that nobody was interested in what she had to say. Felix has never provided an explanation as to how he knew that Kevin's shoes were behind the shed near the lake. One year after Don Yusufsson and his documentary team started digging around,
凯文的家人向当局表达了他们的担忧，但被告知凯文的案件已经结案，就是这样。罗宾和克里斯蒂安的母亲也觉得菲利克斯没有被进一步调查很奇怪。她联系了警察和媒体以探讨可能的联系，但似乎没有人对她的话感兴趣。菲利克斯从未解释过他是如何知道凯文的鞋子在湖边棚子后面的。在唐·尤素夫森和他的纪录片团队开始挖掘一年后，
they sat down with Robin, Christian and their parents and presented them with the interrogation videos. The family was absolutely flawed. Although they'd always suspected that Robin and Christian were innocent, they'd been completely oblivious to how the interrogation was going to go. Vyner didn't know whether to laugh or cry. After digesting what they'd seen, Christian remarked, Every question mark is erased for me.
他们与罗宾、克里斯蒂安及其父母坐在一起，向他们展示了审讯视频。这个家庭完全被击垮了。虽然他们一直怀疑罗宾和克里斯蒂安是无辜的，但他们完全不知道审讯会是这样进行的。维娜不知道该笑还是该哭。在消化了他们所看到的一切后，克里斯蒂安评论道：“对我来说，每一个问号都被抹去了。”
When the three-part documentary titled Documents From Within, the Kevin case aired on Sweden's SVT network in early 2016, the three-part documentary titled Documents From Within, the Kevin case aired on Sweden's SVT network in early May of 2017, Robin, Christian and their parents were extremely anxious. They feared the exposure might lead to a backlash. However, they received nothing but overwhelming support from the community who were completely outraged at the way the authorities had handled the investigation. In a subsequent press conference, Robin and Christian's full names were released to the
当名为《来自内部的文件：凯文案》的三集纪录片于2017年5月初在瑞典SVT网络播出时，罗宾、克里斯蒂安和他们的父母非常焦虑。他们担心曝光可能会导致反弹。然而，他们从社区那里得到了压倒性的支持，社区对当局处理调查的方式感到非常愤怒。在随后的新闻发布会上，罗宾和克里斯蒂安的全名首次向
public for the first time. The brothers spoke of the joy and relief they felt after the bungled investigation had been exposed and thanked the media for helping bring the truth to light. Instead of living in fear of being recognized, they embraced the spotlight and welcomed people who approached to wish them well. Robin told reporters, This is a new start. We'll just keep trying to lead an ordinary life. Work, house, car.
公众发布。兄弟俩谈到了在拙劣的调查被曝光后他们感到的喜悦和解脱，并感谢媒体帮助真相大白。他们不再生活在被认出的恐惧中，而是拥抱了聚光灯，欢迎那些走过来祝愿他们好运的人。罗宾告诉记者：“这是一个新的开始。我们将继续努力过普通人的生活。工作、房子、车子。”
Not much planned beyond that. Ordinary life goals. Christian commented, They have taken years of my life that I will never ever get back. Now when new chapter begins, one can finally settle down. I do not need to be afraid anymore. The brothers voiced their concerns for Kevin's family who would no doubt have old wounds reopened. Christian told reporters, It is tragic, both for us who were suspected and also for Kevin's family who now have to go through all of this once again.
“没有计划太多。普通的生活目标。”克里斯蒂安评论道：“他们夺走了我生命中几年，我永远也找不回来了。现在新篇章开始了，终于可以安定下来了。我不再需要害怕了。”兄弟俩表达了对凯文家人的担忧，他们的旧伤无疑会被重新揭开。克里斯蒂安告诉记者：“这很悲惨，对我们这些被怀疑的人来说是这样，对现在不得不再次经历这一切的凯文的家人来说也是这样。”
With the story gaining huge attention in the media, the case was formally reviewed by chief prosecutor Nicholas Vargrian. He dissected the interrogation records, reviewed Kevin's autopsy report, and interviewed over 80 people who had been involved in the initial investigation. On March 17, 10 months after the documentary aired, Vargrian held a press conference to announce his verdict. He concluded that there was absolutely no forensic evidence to indicate that Robin and Christian were involved in Kevin's death in any way or that they were even present when he died.
随着这个故事在媒体上获得巨大关注，该案由首席检察官尼古拉斯·瓦格里安（Nicholas Vargrian）进行了正式审查。他剖析了审讯记录，审查了凯文的尸检报告，并采访了80多名参与初步调查的人员。在纪录片播出10个月后的3月17日，瓦格里安举行了新闻发布会宣布他的裁决。他得出结论，绝对没有任何法医证据表明罗宾和克里斯蒂安以任何方式参与了凯文的死亡，甚至表明他们在凯文死亡时在场。
Not only did they have a verified alibi from the very beginning, but the interrogation methods used against them were entirely unethical and unprofessional. Vargrian had no doubts about it, both Christian and Robin were entirely innocent. The brothers were over the moon at finally being vindicated. After the announcement, Christian told reporters, I haven't been able to digest it, so I can only describe it as pure happiness. They subsequently applied for financial compensation for the hardships they faced, but their application was rejected on the grounds that too much time had passed.
他们不仅从一开始就有经过核实的不在场证明，而且针对他们使用的审讯方法完全是不道德和不专业的。瓦格里安对此毫无疑问，克里斯蒂安和罗宾完全是无辜的。兄弟俩终于被平反，感到欣喜若狂。宣布后，克里斯蒂安告诉记者：“我还没能消化它，所以我只能把它描述为纯粹的幸福。”他们随后申请了经济赔偿以弥补他们所面临的困难，但他们的申请以时间过长为由被拒绝了。
With the botched murder investigation exposed, it raised a serious question. If Robin and Christian didn't kill Kevin, then who did? Chief prosecutor Nicholas Vargrian believed there were several possibilities. While he wasn't prepared to completely rule out drowning or that Kevin might have been killed by someone other than the brothers, it was more likely that he had died by accident. Judging by the injuries to his body, it was possible that Kevin had been playing by the lake, either alone or with another child, when a wooden pallet accidentally fell on top of him while trying to lift it. The other child might have panicked, moved the pallet and then fled the
随着拙劣的谋杀调查被曝光，它提出了一个严重的问题。如果罗宾和克里斯蒂安没有杀害凯文，那么是谁杀的？首席检察官尼古拉斯·瓦格里安认为有几种可能性。虽然他没有准备好完全排除溺水或凯文可能被兄弟俩以外的人杀害的可能性，但他更有可能是死于意外。从他身体上的伤痕来看，凯文可能是在湖边玩耍时，无论是独自一人还是与其他孩子在一起，在试图抬起一个木托盘时，托盘意外地掉在他身上。另一个孩子可能惊慌失措，移开了托盘，然后逃离了现场。
scene, vowing never to speak a word about what had happened. Alternatively, Kevin might have been Kevin might have been playing with another child who could have sat on top of him, pushing his neck into the edge of the pallet and accidentally strangling him. The prosecutor concluded that exactly what happened to Kevin would likely never be uncovered. Kevin's father, Patrick, told the media that he would now have to learn to accept a new truth. He remarked, For almost 20 years I thought it was murder. Now it looks like it was child's play ending in an accident. Believing something for such a long time, then everything changes, it's going to be a process
现场，并发誓绝口不提所发生的一切。另一种可能是，凯文当时可能在和另一个孩子玩耍，那个孩子可能坐在他身上，将他的脖子压在托盘边缘，意外导致他窒息。检察官总结说，凯文身上到底发生了什么可能永远无法查明。凯文的父亲帕特里克告诉媒体，他现在必须学会接受一个新的事实。他评论道：近20年来，我一直以为那是谋杀。现在看来，那是一场以意外告终的儿戏。长期以来一直相信某件事，然后一切都变了，这需要一个过程
to get through. Christian, Robin and their parents wanted to do something to ensure that Kevin Jullmeson would be remembered not just as a name in a news headline, but as the happy, friendly and confident little boy they remembered him to be. They also wanted to heal the wounds that the case had created for the city of Arvika. With the blessing of Kevin's family, they created the Kevin Foundation, an organization that would honor Kevin's memory while awarding two scholarships a year to vulnerable teenagers in Arvika in a field of their choosing. The Foundation aimed to reward those who fought against all odds to succeed academically. For years after Kevin's death, Kevin's mother,
来度过。克里斯蒂安、罗宾和他们的父母想做点什么，以确保凯文·朱尔梅森被记住的不仅仅是新闻标题中的一个名字，而是他们记忆中那个快乐、友好、自信的小男孩。他们还想治愈这起案件给阿尔维卡市造成的创伤。在凯文家人的祝福下，他们成立了凯文基金会，这是一个旨在纪念凯文的组织，每年向阿尔维卡弱势青少年颁发两项他们所选领域的奖学金。该基金会旨在奖励那些克服重重困难在学业上取得成功的人。在凯文去世后的几年里，凯文的母亲，
Therese, was haunted by the accusations that she was a bad parent. Those years filled with mourning and resentment had blended into one, and she looked back at them as a fog. After the truth was finally revealed, she was relieved to find solace with Eva and Vyner, with whom she formed a close bond. Like them, Therese had reluctantly accepted the police explanation that Robin and Christian had confessed to killing Kevin, despite questioning it herself for 20 years. She was relieved that the truth had been exposed, even if it meant that the mystery of Kevin's death remained. When the initial investigation was underway, nobody made any objections to the way things were handled, and after Kevin's murder was solved, Rolf Sundberry was promoted to chief
特蕾丝一直被她是坏家长的指责所困扰。那些充满哀悼和怨恨的岁月交织在一起，她回首往事时，感觉就像一片迷雾。真相最终大白后，她很欣慰能从伊娃和维纳那里找到慰藉，并与他们建立了密切的联系。和他们一样，特蕾丝不情愿地接受了警方的解释，即罗宾和克里斯蒂安承认杀害了凯文，尽管她自己对此质疑了20年。她很欣慰真相终于大白，即使这意味着凯文死亡的谜团依然存在。在最初的调查过程中，没有人对处理方式提出异议，在凯文谋杀案破获后，罗尔夫·桑德伯里被提升为
of Vermland Police. Two years before the documentary team reexamined the case, Sundberry suffered a head injury that affected his memory. Yet, he recalled that the brothers had been very clear about their confession and denied any wrongdoing. According to the book, The Story of the Kevin Case, after Christian and Robin's names were officially cleared, Christian called the child psychiatrist Bent Joran Johansson who he had worked with closely for 20 years, wanting an explanation. However, Johansson never returned Christian's calls. Neither Johansson nor lead investigator Rolf Sundberry, interrogation leader Ingrid Harrison, or Professor Sven Orke Kristiansson have apologized to the family.
韦姆兰警察局局长。在纪录片团队重新审查此案的两年前，桑德伯里头部受伤，影响了他的记忆力。然而，他回忆说，兄弟俩在供述时非常清楚，并否认有任何不当行为。据《凯文案的故事》一书所述，在克里斯蒂安和罗宾的名字被正式洗清后，克里斯蒂安给与他密切合作了20年的儿童精神病学家本特·乔兰·约翰逊打电话，想要一个解释。然而，约翰逊从未回过克里斯蒂安的电话。约翰逊、首席调查员罗尔夫·桑德伯里、审讯负责人英格丽德·哈里森以及斯文·奥尔克·克里斯蒂安森教授都没有向这家人道歉。
In March 2022, Robin and Christian were reached finally awarded compensation of one million krona from the Swedish government in recognition of the wrongdoing. Announcing the payment, Sweden's Justice Minister said, When the state makes a mistake, the state must take the consequences and try to put things right. Today, Robin and Christian are both fathers, a role they each revel in. They refuse to be bitter about the situation that impacted their childhood and haunted them for 20 years. When they were publicly declared innocent, their father Vyner wiped tears from his eyes as he told reporters. It's absolutely incredible. It's so wonderful after so many years.
2022年3月，罗宾和克里斯蒂安最终获得了瑞典政府100万克朗的赔偿，以承认其不当行为。瑞典司法部长在宣布这笔赔偿时表示：当国家犯错时，国家必须承担后果并努力纠正错误。今天，罗宾和克里斯蒂安都已为人父，他们都很享受这个角色。他们拒绝为影响了他们童年并困扰了他们20年的情况感到痛苦。当他们被公开宣布无罪时，他们的父亲维纳擦去眼中的泪水，告诉记者：这简直不可思议。这么多年过去了，真是太好了。
Finally, finally, it's all right. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
终于，终于，一切都好了。你目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。